hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show you got a lot to get to
here today newspapers across America
uniting to condemn President Trump we
examine why it's so easy to
misunderstand how evil works and John
Brennan wines a lot I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show as I say so many
things to get to hear today lots and
lots to get to hear today but first
let's talk about your impending death
life insurance is really important but
it's also really confusing no wonder
four out of ten people don't have it
maybe you are one of those people you
hear in the audience you don't think
you're gonna die but one day you will
I'm sorry to break it to you and that's
why life insurance is necessary
life insurance rates are the lowest
they've been in 20 years the best time
to buy is now the best place to buy is
policy genius.com
cut policy genius is the easy way to
compare life insurance online in just
five minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers and find the best
policy for you and when you compare
quotes you save money it is indeed
that's simple policy genius has helped
over 4 million people shop for insurance
they've placed over 20 billion dollars
in coverage and they don't just do life
insurance to do health insurance and
disability insurance and renter's
insurance all the rest of it if you've
been putting off getting your life
insurance there is no reason to put it
off any longer go to policy genius com
get quotes applying minutes it's that
easy you could do it right now
and you should because rates are their
lowest in 20 years and if you die and
leave your family bereft they won't be
able to pay for a nice headstone for you
so go check it out right now
policy genius it is the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance that's
policy genius.com
so we begin today with the fact that 300
newspapers 300 newspapers across the
country have all decided that it is
deeply necessary and important to come
out against President Trump 300
newspapers all across the country this
thing was led by the Boston Globe the
Boston Globe coordinated this entire
stick and I guess the idea here is to
show that the media is not in collusion
against President Trump by colluding
against President Trump it makes perfect
sense all the way across the board
the Boston Globe has its own very long
editorial all about this and they write
a central pillar of President Trump's
politics is a sustained assault on the
Free Press journalists are not
classified as fellow Americans but
rather the enemy of the people
this relentless assault on the Free
Press has dangerous consequences
we asked editorial boards from across
the country liberal and conservative
large and small but mostly liberal to
join us today to address this
fundamental threats in their own words
than their hundreds of editorials and
they show some poll results about how
much Americans trust the press and what
these poll results show it's kind of
fascinating is that it's not just a
matter of conservatives not trusting the
press a lot of people don't trust the
press about 26% of all independents say
the news media are the enemy of the
American people that's registered
independents not Republicans not
Democrats and when you look at the
numbers with regard to for example the
New York Times what you see is that only
about 37% of independents actually about
37% believe the New York Times is
untrustworthy about 60% believe it's
trustworthy well you would figure that
independence if the New York Times were
actually trustworthy independence would
be up near 100% are you'd figure
Republicans would be 100% against
Democrats would be 100% for and
independence would be 100% for cuz
independents are independent minded
instead it turns out that the New York
Times can only get about 6 and 10 even
from independence but I guess we're
supposed to believe that all of the
distrust of the media began with
President Trump and that's what the
Boston Globe says the Boston Globe says
that the president is stoking domestic
division for political and personal gain
he's asking his audiences to follow him
into fantasia his they quote President
Trump saying this just stick with us
don't believe the crap you see from
these people the
newse just remember what you're seeing
in what you're reading is not what's
happening and the Boston Globe says this
sounds like George Orwell's 1984 the
problem of course is that the media have
been engaged in undermining their own
credibility for quite a while now the
the suggestion that the media are just
good stewards of the truth and that only
when President Trump levels these unfair
nasty attacks and people that's when
things go wrong it's just not true in
any sense there's no evidence for it
okay the in fact the evidence is all on
the other side Republicans have been
anti media since long before I was born
you know I was writing about how
terrible the media was when I first
started writing when I was 17 years old
the media has been garbage when it comes
to reporting an objective truth for as
long as I have been alive and as long as
many of the people in this audience have
been alive and then they're shocked when
President Trump says this is all fake
news and then people will start to
ignore the news well President Trump
wasn't going to leave well enough alone
President Trump jumped on Twitter and
did what President Trump does best
that's right
Jude said some crap
because that's a shtick right as they
say many times on the show the president
on his headstone you know when his time
comes after 120 years when the president
goes on his headstone it'll say 45th
presidents of the United States he sent
a lot of crap so here is what President
Trump had says had to say that the fake
news media is the opposition party it is
very bad for a great country but we are
winning and it's hard not to see the
fake news media as the opposition party
when 300 of them are coordinating to
attack the administration and to attack
Trump remember what President Trump has
done in terms of policy to crack down on
the news media is not even remotely
comparable to what the Obama
administration actually did to crack
down on certain members of the news
media they legitimately wiretapped
people like James Rosen at Fox News they
wiretap The Associated Press so
president from says many things but I
think a lot of us become background
noises the truth most Americans know
that when President Trump says stuff
it's because he says a lot of stuff but
don't worry he said more stuff so here
is what he said he said now this one is
real galaxy brain I I can't
really I pulled over this one for a
while and I couldn't come to any clear
conclusion as to what it's supposed to
say maybe we are just maybe maybe he's
operating on a different plane I mean I
think he is but I don't think it's the
way that most people think is here's why
he says the Boston Globe which was sold
to the failing New York Times for one
point three billion dollars plus eight
hundred million dollars in losses and
investment or 2.1 billion dollars was
then sold by the Times for $1
now the globe is in collusion with other
papers and Free Press prove it
I sort of feel like Winona Ryder at the
Oscars just kind of looking around
randomly trying to figure out what
exactly this is supposed to mean I mean
it is good to know the president can add
together 1.3 billion and 800 million
that's good
hey that part of his math is good but I
don't know what the rest of this tweet
means I am not I'm not sure and then
what I like at the very end is when he
says prove it like he's gonna say prove
it Inspector Clouseau is gonna bust
through the doors like I have the proof
right Sherlock Holmes is going to wander
in Ozone say sir I've proven it like I
don't I don't understand what this is
but you know president saying stuff and
the stuff continues so he finishes up
this way he says there is nothing that I
would want more for our country then
true freedom of the press the fact is
that the press is free to write and say
anything it was but much of what it says
is fake news pushing a political agenda
or just plain trying to hurt people
honesty wins okay so again I have a lot
of sympathy for this position there's a
certain irony just to be perfectly frank
and the president placing in all capital
letters letters honesty wins but I mean
even with that said what he is saying is
basically true and the media cannot
fathom why it is that so many people do
not trust them well the clearest example
of why people do not trust the
mainstream media to be found is the
narrative over the past 48 hours over
the taking away of John Brennan security
clearance so John Brennan was the head
of the CIA under Barack Obama and John
Brennan is a garbage heap John Brennan
is just terrible
John Brendan lied to the American
Congress any full-scale lied to them he
said that people weren't being
surveilled when they were being a
surveilled and John Brennan was
instrumental in pushing information that
was not good enough to actually indict
President Trump on or to get the Trump
campaign on with regard to collusion he
was instrumental in pushing all of that
information over to Harry Reid he was
instrumental in making sure that all of
it hit the press and then he goes on
television and he says a lot of things
about how collusion is real he has an
editorial in the New York Times today
about how collusion is real I kid you
not write it it's a full-on editorial
and the title of it is President Trump's
claims of no collusion are hogwash that
is the name of the column and then he
goes through about 800 words and you're
waiting for him to actually prove this
thing okay well if you are the big truth
teller if you are the great truth teller
who ought to retain your security
clearance maybe you ought to provide
some proof that the collusion actually
happened but you get all the way through
the article and there's nothing there
and here's what he says he says mr.
Trump's claims of no collusion are in a
word hogwash the only questions that
remain are whether the collusion that
took place constituted criminally liable
conspiracy whether obstruction of
justice occurred to cover up any
collusion or conspiracy and how many
members of Trump incorporated attempted
to defraud the government by laundering
and concealing the movement of money
into their pockets now I need to take
that more slowly so you understand how
absurd that statement is ray says
there's no the claims have no clue janar
hogwash the only things we have to know
are were there what did collusion happen
that's really what he's saying he's
saying absolutely collusion happened the
only question yet to be answered is
whether collusion actually happened and
then he cites Paul Manafort who there
are no accusations in Paul Manafort
trial that Paul Manafort actually
colluded with the Russians to affect the
election in any way that is not part of
Paul Manafort trial by the way Paul
Manafort may get off the jury sent a
note to the judge today asking the
definition of reasonable doubt I used to
work in a prosecutor's office that's
never a good sign
he says that Rick Gates raises Rick
Gates has involved inclusion again there
is no evidence that Rick Gates is
involved in any collusion between the
Trump campaign and the Russian
government all of the charges with
regard to mana four and gates predate
their involvement with the Trump
campaign but Brendon concludes his piece
in The New York Times thusly he says mr.
Trump clearly has become more desperate
to protect himself in those close to him
which is why he made the politically
motivated decision to revoke my security
clearance in an attempt to scare into
silence others who might dare challenge
him yes clearly Brennan has been
frightened into silence in the pages of
the New York Times clearly the president
has been over successful at shutting
John Brennan down say says that it's
important that the special counsel does
work so the entire left has come out in
support of John Brennan ignoring the
fact that John Brennan has been a
corrupt official that he has been
extraordinarily political since leaving
office and honestly there should be a
blanket rule that when you leave office
and you're no longer part of the
administration you probably should lose
your security clearance anyway I'm very
confused I'm confused by folks who say
that there's some sort of right to keep
your security security clearance after
you leave off it's like do you really
think the Trump administration is gonna
call up John Brennan for advice it's
never going to happen there's no reason
for any of that to happen but the media
have jumped on this with both feet and
we'll get to that in just a second but
first let's talk about the possibility
of an emergency when an emergency
strikes what is your first impulse if
your answer is run to the grocery store
you're likely to find chaos and nothing
but empty shelves how do you avoid all
of this well it's pretty easy
use today and you make a plan you're
prepared and one practical place to
start is storing up food in your home
you can trust my Patriot supply for your
food storage so you'll be ready for
earthquakes hurricanes long term power
outages and more here's a great special
that makes it simple every person in
your household should have a two-week
emergency food supply from my Patriot
supply these kids are just 75 bucks
right now
they contain 92 servings of breakfasts
lunches and dinners take action call
eight eight eight eight oh three 14 13
or go to my special website prepare with
been calm listen the government
recommends they have some food in your
house in case of emergency because they
may not be able to get to you and you
never want to be reliant on the
government anyway this makes sure that
you and your family are safe if god
forbid people can't get to you and you
need food the food lasts up to 25 years
in storage meals compact in a rugged
slimline tote - it is only 75 bucks rest
tonight knowing that you're prepared
order your food kit
888 803 1413 or at prepare with Ben comm
make sure you are not left unprepared
prepare with Ben calm so the argument
from the left with regard to John
Brennan is that John Brennan actually
had a right to keep his security
clearance now President Trump did what
President Trump does as I've said many
times he said stuff about this now he
didn't actually have to say stuff about
this what he should have just said is ya
chump Brendan didn't like that guy he
worked for the Obama administration
don't trust him no security clearance
instead he decided that he was going to
do a 20-minute impromptu interview with
The Wall Street Journal
I swear I'm being president from Sandler
it's like watching my two and a half
year old son
hey you just did I'm rooting for him but
I know that if I don't watch him for
five seconds he's gonna break his face
on something so he told the Wall Street
Journal during this 20 minute impromptu
interview who said I called the rigged
witch hunt a sham and these people let
it so I think it's something that had to
be done
okay well that's partially true but the
problem is when it makes it look like
it's a political hit when it looks like
you're pursuing a political hit against
your political opponents people are
likely going to complain about it and
complain that their First Amendment
rights have been violated that you're
discriminating against them on the basis
of their politics from a governmental
point of view all he had to do is just
say listen John Brennan security
clearance is gone instead he listed
basically all the people he doesn't like
and then he said I'm taking your
security security clearance which wasn't
supremely smart however the overblown
reaction to this is truly something to
watch
so John Brennan right who is a
hysterical hisi just pissy human being
John Brennan goes on national television
and he starts ranting and raving about
tyrants and despots remember this is the
guy who lied to the Congress of the
United States about whether he is spying
on you and he is talking about how it's
tyrannical despotism for his security
clearance that he hasn't used in over
two years to be removed from him John
Brennan one of the geniuses of our age
I've seen this type of behavior and
actions on the part of foreign tyrants
and despots and autocrats for many many
years during my CIA and a security
career I never ever thought that I would
see it here in the I stay absolutely
how dare somebody remove a piece of
paper he wasn't using and that he had no
right to have in the first place how
dare this happened and the media of
course blow this up to gargantuan
proportions they find everyone they can
to come out and talk about this the
latest person who they have brought out
to talk about this he's retired Admiral
William McRaven most famous for having
been the guy who oversaw the the
operation that ended with the death of
Osama bin Laden so there's a full op-ed
in the Washington Post by Admiral
McRaven talking about how terrible it is
that John Brennan security clearance was
removed and here is what his op-ed had
to say he said few Americans have done
more to protect this country than John
he is a man of unparalleled integrity
whose honesty and character have never
been in question except by those who
don't know him and people who watch TV I
mean Admiral McRaven did some wonderful
things but Admiral McRaven is in fact a
Democrat who doesn't like President
Trump he's spoken out against President
Trump many times before and yet this is
being touted as some sort of great
evidence that President Trump did
something deeply wrong now the hilarious
thing is that past administrations have
used their power to strip paperwork away
from people before you remember early on
in the Clinton administration for
example they removed a bunch of people
in the travel office in the travel
office who they didn't like and it's
called travelgate nothing ever came of
it this sort of thing isn't remarkably
uncommon but the fact that media decide
to over blow it it's just more evidence
that the media are who the media are
which is why they feel the necessity to
in unison all 300 papers unite and talk
about President Trump meanwhile the
media have decided that they're going to
increase their capacity to to go after
President Trump by continuing to push
forward Omarosa Manigault so I'm Rosa
Manigault will not leave she has now
been fired I kid you not
she was fired let's see twice by the
Clinton administration you know that did
you she worked for the she worked for
Gore in the Clinton administration she's
fired twice by the Clinton
administration then she was fired three
times on the apprentice and now she's
been fired once by the Trump White House
and undoubtedly at some point she'll say
something nice Trump will hire again and
then fire her again so this is I think I
think that it is inevitable that she
will eventually enter double digits in
terms of the number of times that she is
fired so she was on MSNBC
and she is talking about how she has
brand-new tapes now Omarosa is desperate
for money this is a woman of course who
was most famous for being nearly
sociopathic on the
Prentis and then Trump in a brilliant
piece of hiring decided let's bring her
into the White House which was not it
didn't quite fall under his rubric of
hiring all the best people but he hired
her anyway in any case she now has taped
everyone in the White House and I talked
to folks in the White House and
everybody thinks they're on tape from
Omarosa because she was pretty much
walking around the White House like John
Cusack and say anything with a boom box
with a tape recorder in it so she went
on MSNBC today to talk about her newest
tape now her tapes are really big
nothing burgers nothing that she's
broken via tape so far is really of any
worth like she went out her first tape
was John Kelly fired me okay right cuz
you're terrible of course John Kelly
fired you it's just a shot that he
hadn't fired you before then there was a
tape of her and Trump talking about how
Trump didn't know that she was fired and
that's just because Trump actually the
dirty little secret his Trump doesn't
like firing people but he likes other
people to fire people for him so there
was that tape that came out not a big
deal then she has a new tape is it the
dastardly and word tape we've been
hearing so much about no it's a tape of
her talking to Larry Trump right the
least known of the Trump's and nice lady
but I mean just because her last name is
Trump doesn't mean that she is deeply
important to American politics in a way
that merits this sort of conversation
Omarosa releases tape of Lara Trump and
what is large from doing she's offering
her 15,000 dollars a month to join the
campaign which has happened in virtually
everyone who's ever left the Trump
employ everyone ends up on their feet
inside a super PAC org from campaign
that's the way politics works Omarosa
releases this thing on MSNBC and oh it's
the end of the world so here's MSNBC
with Omarosa treating her as though
she's a whistleblower in a Hollywood
movie when all that happened was
somebody offered her a bunch of money to
go be useless at another place
[Music]
the media treated this as those as a
giant payoff oh wow Lehrer Trump is
trying to pay off amorosa it's not a
giant payoff this is how politics works
you leave one place you get a job at
another there's nothing special here but
the media of course went wild over this
and then they wonder why we don't trust
them they're so desperate to get Trump
that they will do legitimately anything
Penn Jillette who's a magician and also
a libertarian he was on the apprentice
as as one of the people on the
apprentice with from and he did an
interview in which he talked about Trump
says kind of raunchy things off camera
which yes we know and then he suggested
that he wouldn't actually he didn't
think that Trump had said the n-word but
he wasn't going to say specifically what
he thought Trump is said because he just
didn't remember this prompted Stephen
Colbert the execrable Stephen Colbert
who was Yabu is right Stephen Colbert he
decided that he was going to try to get
Penn Jillette to say the N word to say
that Trump actually said the N word
the desperation that just ripples off
these people in waves is astonishing
look at the desperation in Stephen
Colbert trying to convince Penn Jillette
to please
please provide the political kill shot
that will take down the president okay
pick through the word that Donald Trump
said I want you to picture I want you to
picture I want you to picture what that
card was do you have it firmly in mind
picture picture the word he said do you
have the word in mind is this your word
this is this is what passes for comedy
these days is basically just shouting
about how President Trump is a racist
and again all this goes back to that
fundamental question as to why the media
have earned artists trust but it really
isn't even the political stuff in which
the media has earned our distrust it's
the cultural stuff because the truth is
it's the media's level of scorn for
people like you people like me people
like everybody in this audience it's the
level of scorn for everybody who does
not live in LA or New York or believe
the same things that they do it's that
level of scorn that really drives our
distrust of the media because we feel
like every time they make an error
there's an agenda behind the error every
time they are dishonest it's not just
that they've lied about something is
that there is a true agenda behind the
dishonesty so the best example of this
that I could find today
was Trevor Noah Trevor Noah who as I've
been saying for a long time is in a
running gun better indeed boo so Trevor
Noah who's been in a running gun battle
for least funny human being in the
United States with Amy Schumer and
Samantha bee Samantha bee is out in
front by by a length and then Trevor
Noah is is running a narrow second
followed by Amy Schumer that says Amy
Schumer hasn't made a movie in like
three months
but it you know all three of them are
pretty awful in any in any case Trevor
Noah
ends on Comedy Central and he decides to
go after the Catholic Church now the
reason this is bad is not because
everybody isn't horrified by the latest
stories we talked about it yesterday on
the podcast the latest stories about
what's going on inside the Catholic
Church the cover-ups inside the Catholic
Church there's a story in Pennsylvania
300 priests were basically covered up
for by the archdiocese in Pennsylvania a
thousand kids who are abused minimum is
really horrifying horrifying stuff but
as I said on my podcast yesterday and a
couple of days ago it is deeply
important to recognize that institutions
that deal with children routinely have
problems with this and they routinely
cover things up and that's not an excuse
for the Catholic Church in any way but
it is to suggest that singling out the
Catholic Church as uniquely evil in this
way is being intellectually dishonest
hey can you can say that it's evil the
treatment here is evil their treatment
of the priest is evil the treatment of
the kids evil you can say all of that
because Catholics will agree with you
right every you Catholic who saw this
thing was sick to their stomach
over the past week there's not a single
Catholic in America or anywhere around
the world who saw this story and saw how
these priests were treated who didn't
feel sick to their stomach and if you're
a religious person of any stripe you
should feel sick to your stomach that
any religious institution would cover up
for that but listen to what Trevor Noah
has to say about it because this is a
bridge further than that and this is why
people in sort of mainstream America
people who believe in God people who are
religious feel that the media are coming
after them hammer and tongs and are just
waiting for an opportunity to stab us in
the eye just in Pennsylvania like we're
not even counting the rest of America
and Europe and Africa and I'm sorry guys
at some point I feel like we need to
stop calling at a church and start
calling it what it is
I'm a less-than Club with an opening
prayer because that's what it feels like
that's an amazing statement right the
Catholic Church is now molesting club
with an opening prayer
so question for Trevor Noah he works in
Hollywood Hollywood not quite known for
its shall we say sexual limits Hollywood
where Roman Polanski wins an Oscar after
raping a fourteen-year-old girl
Hollywood where Woody Allen is still
working Hollywood were Harvey Weinstein
worked for years and years and years
side by side with people like Trevor
Noah
how many people does Trevor Noah know
who've actually abused people
my guess is more than a few he may not
know about the specific abuse but I
promise you there are lots of people in
Hollywood who do sexual abuse in
Hollywood is rampant does he have you
ever heard Trevor Noah say anything like
Hollywood is molestation factory without
an opening prayer have you ever heard
anything like that of course not
about the public schools when you ever
hear anybody on the Left talk about
sexual abuse inside the public schools
there was an Associated Press report
from May 2017 it found 17,000 official
reports official reports of sex assaults
on students from fall 2011 to spring
2015 it's amazing
17,000 official reports we were talking
in Sylvania about 1000 reports over the
course of 30 years here you're talking
about in the public schools 17,000
official reports of sex assaults on
students in four years alone according
to Hofstra University researcher Cheryl
Shake shaft who performs a study for the
DIA the Department of Education in 2002
the physical sexual abuse of students in
schools is likely more than 100 times
the abuse by priests a federal report
found four hundred and twenty-two
thousand California public school
students would be victimized by sexual
abuse before graduation which was every
time more than the entire California
Catholic school enrollment it was a
survey from the American Association of
University Women it found that 1 in 10
students from 8th to 11th grade said
they'd been subjected to sexual comments
pornography peeping or sexual contact
from a teacher or school employee which
would mean four point five million
students across America between
kindergarten and 12th grade who suffered
sexual abuse by an educator have you
ever heard anybody on the Left talked
about any of that stuff of course not
even when the media reported it's
relegated to secondary status which is
one of the reasons why media will say
yeah well we covered it right but did
you cover it with the same sort of
alacrity and anger that you cover abuse
in the Catholic Church if the answer is
no I have to assume the reason you are
covering the Catholic Church differently
then
cover the sanctified public schools is
because you like the public schools and
you don't like the Catholic Church that
is the rationale and it feels like every
day there's a new assault from the left
on fundamental values that the New York
Times is constantly promoting a certain
agenda with regard to key values that we
all hold dear right key values like you
know mothers and fathers I have to have
to go through this there's a great
editorial and when I'm great I mean it's
just awful freakin garbage over the New
York Times by a guy named Kevin Noble
maelard he is a professor I believe at
Syracuse University and he was working
on a book about modern fatherhood in
America which is always a bad sign his
the title of his pieces when being a
good dad gets you promoted to mommy okay
and here's what he says he says I'm a
sucker for dramatic homecomings I love
stories of reunited siblings and I
devour videos of dogs greeting returning
soldiers but I participate in my own
reunion spectacle every weekday when I
pick up my three-year-old from preschool
she charges at me like I'm an unattended
bowl of cheddar goldfish mommy she
squeals horseshoeing is the dude
horseshoeing her tiny arms around my
neck before she calls the emotion with
the demand for food mommy you have snack
my partner mama who is female is not
there I like that we have to clarify all
these things now not my wife my partner
mama , who is female thanks for that
he says when our daughter says mommy
she's talking to me her father when my
partner heard about this
she left it's always weird to hear
people who have a child together talk
about their partners is that they formed
in an LLC to have the kid since neither
one of us corrected our daughter we
assumed it was all part of language
development then she went all in
announcing that she has two mommies to
the amusement of the lesbian parents at
school yeah I have um used to because
I'm a professor of family law so it's my
job to analyze these types of
occurrences as part of some larger issue
well then we are paying you too much
money my friend as in this case I'm
intrigued by children's selection of
names for their parents and what it
possibly signifies you know it probably
signifies that your kids a kid and it's
kind of dumb okay breaking news as the
father of kids two kids under five kids
are stupid man I mean like I love them
they're really smart for their age my
daughter is brilliant for her age which
means that she's four and a half and she
takes a violin lesson and she can play
like uh note and it means that she is on
the verge of reading and it means that
if she were twenty she'd be really
stupid because when you're
four-and-a-half and dumb right and so if
my daughter is calling me Mommy or
calling my wife daddy or something fair
assumption that she hasn't come up with
some grand sociological scheme to
rejigger the definition of gender in
American society most likely it's that
she's dumb but no but no according to
the New York Times this is an indicator
of something deep and profound happening
shifting within the nature of gender in
the United States
this guy says our other child to his
five called both parents mama when he
started talking maybe it's just that
maybe if both your kids doing it now I'm
starting to have suspicions our other
child who's five called both parents
mama when he started talking it must
have meant old person because he once
called our neighbor a six year old
southern man mama again going back to my
theory the kids are dumb at the time I
was amused but slightly worried that
this baby was bestowing maternity on
anyone who held him I tried to steer him
toward Papa but that was too much
consonantal labor for this particular in
from infants he settled on me me I was
never threatened then this is the best
part I was never thrilled about the
actual name Dada which in American
culture is someone who tells bad jokes
and wears socks with sandals this part
actually this is where we get into the
culture gap when I think of my own
father my father is a deeply devout
human being a deeply responsible human
by the way my mom worked my dad was at
home because my mom was the breadwinner
my mom went out and she worked all day
and my dad was home raising us okay he
was still my dad because you know the
basic definition of dad honestly when
you boil all the other things out the
basic definition of dad is when it's
time for an ass-whooping who do you call
there is not a teenage boy on earth
who's afraid of his mother it just
doesn't work that way hey dad is the guy
who is there to instill values and make
sure those values are instilled dad is
the guy who's makes sure they're to make
sure that there is responsibility that
is implemented in the children and mom
is there for comfort now both parents
have roles in both of those areas but
those roles do have differentiation men
have a more primary role when it comes
to instilling virtue and ensuring that
particularly boys are prepared for
taking responsibility and making sure
that girls feel protected and mom is
there to make sure that everyone feels
supported right that is the basic
differentiation again my parents did
some both but in my family where I take
care of my I'm actually home with my
kids more than my wife is at this point
because as you may know my wife is a doc
when someone skins their knee it's my
wife's job to come in and fix that now
be true even if she weren't a doctor and
when it's time for the foot to come down
then that's that's my job I want to talk
a little bit more about this in just a
second but first we're gonna have to go
over and subscribe over at daily wire
comm for those of you who are listening
so purchase $9.99 a month you can get a
subscription to daily wire when you do
that you get the rest of this show live
on table you see my face it's magical
you can also get the Andrew Clavin show
live if we ever release Michael moles
from prison then you can see the Michael
Maloy
live as well plus you get to be part of
the mailbag which we will be doing next
week actually and if you spend 99 bucks
then you get this ah yes this it needs
no introduction it is the very greatest
in all beverage vessels it is
magnificent it will make you younger
better-looking it will it is it is a a
life beverage it is fantastic the
leftist here's how to call tumblr that's
for 99 bucks also make sure that you
subscribe over at youtube itunes you can
see our sunday special this week we got
greg gutfeld stopping by so check that
out we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
soda can to continue with this guy's
idiotic piece over the New York Times
and again going back to the theme the
reason that we distrust the media is
because they're constantly promulgating
this sort of cultural change under the
guise of journalism so this professor
writes dad is is not a good guy right
he's the lord of the grill and the Duke
of fix-it he's the best of the good guys
but when it comes to the nitty-gritty of
parenting mom schedules the appointments
buys the clothes and makes the playdates
it is a common division of labor for
most HEC heterosexual couples moms do
more when I moved in with my partner we
talked about gender norms I'll bet you
did my friend said when I was younger I
welcomed gender subversions in pop
culture staples like Kramer vs Kramer
mr. mom mrs. Doubtfire and even that pre
Chuckie my buddy doll as an adult I'm
still trying to do more and then he
quotes in 1953 children's book called
daddies and says what do daddies do all
day daddies work while children play
correct but this is very bad it's very
bad right instead daddy is supposed to
be mommy basically and so he's actually
very pleased that he is called mommy he
just hopes that one day there really
won't be titles mommy and daddy instead
it'll just be smoo I don't know what
term we'll use for mommy and daddy that
is by gender but apparently there's
women says I presented the issue of my
children's naming innovations to a
fellow academic one who speaks fluent
Berkeley which is to say that they were
hit on the head as a child who told me
that the Mimi mommy dialectic is a
liminal space for interpolating and/or
repudiating hegemony parental gender
binaries
at which point everybody ran is I
thought about this mouthful of jargon
for a long time I still think about it I
like most modern men want to be taken
seriously as a parent in my own right
however my kids choose to name me I
think of all the other fathers the
single ones the stay-at-home ones the
gay ones even the dad ones who do more
than earn paychecks and babysit we are
knocking at the door for an interview at
the toughest job in the world waiting to
be let in the idea that if you want to
take care of your kids more hours per
day that this makes you mommy is just a
way to obliterate gender distinctions
it's just a way to pretend that men and
women are exactly the same and they play
exactly the same role that's foolish
it's not the amount of time you spend
with your kids that makes you a mommy or
a daddy it's how you interact with your
kids
it is indeed the quality of that
interaction and the attitude that you
take during that interaction it's
there's a great video on YouTube sort of
contrasting how moms and dads deal with
small children and it shows a mother
with her kid on like a little tricycle
and she's trying to make sure the kid
doesn't fall off the tricycle it's all
really cute and they're moving really
slowly and they have to make sure that
the kid doesn't pull over and then the
dad comes in and that grabs the tricycle
and starts swinging it around the room
men and women are different one of the
most beautiful things in life the fact
that the left wants to obliterate those
distinctions the fact the left wants to
destroy all that is really truly
troubling in a serious way and the
reason why we don't trust people on the
left to promulgate this this sort of
nonsense okay now meanwhile it's not
just people on the left in media tell us
what people on left in social media so
over at Twitter they have decided they
are now going to limit what you can see
Jack Dorsey did an interview this week
he's the head of Twitter in which he
suggested that it was his job to guide
people toward healthier conversation
here's what he had to say we want to
take a broader view in terms of what our
service can provide and that ability to
show some of the darkest places in the
world shine light on them and try to
disarm it and try to engage it in a way
that gets us to a healthier public
conversation where we can all
participate and we can all debate and we
don't fear our safety and we feel
protected that is our goal we are not
here to have Jack Dorsey tell us what a
healthy conversation constitutes or have
him pick for us what we can and cannot
see on Twitter the same people
the same people at the New York Times
who promulgate the worst kinds of ideas
are the same people who are going to
social media and saying should elevate
us as fact tellers and you should
downgrade everybody we disagree with
this is dangerous stuff and it's why so
many people are kicking back against
what actually has become a hegemonic
news media attempting to cramp the
diversity of viewpoints that really
should be exploding in the media
ecosystem and meanwhile I have to tell
you that there's a there's an awful
awful story I want to tell you about
because it says something about human
nature to shift topics for a few minutes
there's this story from the New York
Times by a person named real Kamini
kalamaki
and it's a story of these two people and
their names are Jay Austin and Lauren
Geoghan I think is how it's pronounced
here's what happened they were remember
that they're American citizens and they
decided to go on a bike trip around the
world and they decided to go into areas
that are not particularly safe one of
the areas of the bike trip they went on
was an area in Tajikistan which is right
on the Afghan border and it turns out
that when they did some Isis members is
the first Isis attack in the country I
believe some Isis members basically ran
them off the road with the truck and
then stabbed them to death the reason
that this story is so horrifying is
because what it says about people's view
of evil and human nature and so here's
what the New York Times suggests the New
York Times says asked why they put their
office jobs and set off on a biking
journey around the world the young
American couple offered a simple
explanation they'd grown tired of the
meetings and teleconferences of the time
sheets and password changes there's
magic out there in this great big
beautiful world wrote Jay Austin who
along with his partner Lauren Geoghan
gave his two weeks notice last year
before shipping his bicycle to Africa
and they went you know for more than a
year they just went biking around
everywhere and there on July 29th in in
Tajikistan a carload of men who are
believed to have recorded a video
pledging allegiance to Isis spotted them
a grainy cell phone clip recorded by a
driver shows what happened next
the men's dive was sedan passes the
cyclists and then makes a sharp u-turn
it doubles back aims directly for the
bikers ramming into them and lurching
over their fallen forms and all four
people were killed mr. Austin miss
Geoghan and cyclists from Switzerland
and Netherlands and then Isis released a
video in which they made a pledge to
kill disbelievers the reason that this
story is is worth talking about
because of the worldview of the people
who went biking it's obviously the it's
a tragic terrible terrible story but the
reason that these folks decided they
were going to do this is because what
they said is that evil is a human
construct here's what mr. Austen wrote
before he was killed here well you read
the papers and you're led to believe
that the world is a big scary place
people the narrative goes are not to be
trusted
people are bad people are evil I don't
buy it evil is a make-believe concept
we've invented to deal with the
complexities of fellow humans holding
values and beliefs and perspectives
different than our own by and large
humans are kind self-interested
sometimes myopic sometimes but kind
generous and wonderful and kind no
greater revelation has come from our
journey than this and then of course
they were murdered by Isis it's it's I
mean terrible story but this view is
very very common among folks who tend to
be on the left side of the political
aisle it even includes some folks who
are libertarian ish in the sense that
they believe that there don't
necessarily need to be social systems
that inculcate virtue in children that
people aren't by necessity
self-interested in the self-interest is
good and therefore you can lead people
to their own devices
I generally grant governmental grounds
and do not agree that it is not our job
to instill virtue or that people are by
nature good I don't think people are by
nature good I think people are by nature
capable of both good and capable of evil
now what he says here is kind of
interesting when he says evils and
make-believe concepts we've invented to
deal with complexities of fellow humans
holding values and beliefs and
perspectives different than our own this
suggests that there is no such thing as
an evil value system which of course is
not true there are plenty of evil value
systems and failure to adjudicate
between value systems failure to say
certain value systems are worse than
other value systems allows those value
systems to thrive to rise and to
eventually take over because one of the
great lies that we're told when we're
children is that good is more powerful
than evil good is not more powerful than
evil good can only triumph when there
are lots of good people and a lot fewer
evil people evil is a lot more powerful
than good and this is proof right the
story is proof of that because these
folks went on this bicycle journey all
over the world ninety nine out of every
hundred people they met nice people all
over the world
all it takes is one person who wants to
stab you in the face for their religion
and it turns out that evil wins which is
why we have to be constantly vigilant
for evil it's why we have to build
systems to contain evil and check evil
it's why we have to have a power
military to fight evil it's why we have
to constantly be looking at value
systems in determining whether those
value systems are more likely to create
evil action if we're not actually doing
that then we're not doing our jobs as
moral human beings I believe and it
creates a naive generation of people who
have lived under the protection of the
most powerful military in human history
who've lived under the protection of the
West but believe that the natural state
of human beings is to be like this that
is not true the natural state of human
beings is poverty war and death
Hobbes is right about that okay that's
the natural state of human beings it is
only a civilized system a civilized
worldview a government that is limited
in scope that allows us to live free and
allows us to bring up our children in
such a way that they don't become evil
but instead become good good value
driven human beings that make the world
a better place
all righty so now it's time for some
things I like and then some things I
hate so things I like very sad news that
a recent Aretha Franklin passed today
that obviously everybody is very upset
about and you'll remember her great
performance in Blues Brothers she really
had an unbelievable gift her voice is
just spectacular this is some of the
best Aretha Franklin ever from from
Blues Brothers
[Music]
have you never seen the movie by the way
it's a very funny movie it's and Aretha
Franklin it's worthwhile modem kind of
her place in the culture Aretha Franklin
came about at a time when there was no
such thing really as a black solo female
artist in in the pop genre there were
some jazz artists but but not in in sort
of this area gospel was not a mainstream
form yet and she kind of brought it over
into into the mainstream and of course
you can tell her talent because honestly
like there are a lot of women like Diana
Ross a very good-looking woman Aretha
Franklin was a normal-looking person who
just had an unbelievable gift and so you
know obviously it very sad for her to
pass and her music is gonna live on
beyond her other things that I like so
Glenn Close ready to Hollywood actress
actually said something halfway
intelligent today it was great she was
talking about this it II just idiotic
new movement by the left that says that
you can only play a character if you are
like that character in real life so you
can only print play a transgender person
if you are a transgender person you can
only play a gay person if you are a gay
person you can only play Superman if you
can fly you can only play a space alien
if in fact you descend from Thanos right
you can't that's how all this is gonna
work well Glenn Close
who is still she can get away with this
because she's a major actress has been
in town for four decades she says um I
thought we were actors I thought that
was like our thing say here's what she
had to say people who are producing and
directing properties like that need to
go out of their way to give people like
you know if you're playing trance and
get trans actors jobs but they also
should have the opportunity to cast the
best person I think acting is a craft
you know I think I personally think on
that anyone should be able to play
anyone well it's gonna be very sad when
her career ends because that you're not
allowed to say these sorts of things in
Hollywood anymore and proof of this is
in the things that I hate
[Applause]
there's one of the stars of Queer Eye
for the straight guy I came out and said
that not all Republicans are racist I
know it's a revelation but this person
was destroyed for it so here is what
this this fellow had to say about
Republicans I'm not advocating for
racism I'm definitely not advocating for
Donald Trump who sucks but I am saying
that from the left if you want to get us
into a safer place nationally so that we
can have LGBT rights and we can continue
having equality then we have to be able
to not demonize the right you got
shellacked for this right that's exactly
right this guy's exactly right he
doesn't think like anybody in this room
does probably but that's great that he
actually is willing to recognize that
his career will be over this is the
thing you cannot say on the left well
the left claims they want to reach out
to all of us they don't actually want to
reach out to all of us they prefer to
call everybody on this side of the aisle
a Nazi and a racist and a terrible
person and then castigate us for our
immorality it makes it very comfortable
for them to push crappy policy you never
have to justify your policy if the guy
on the other side is a Nazi but this but
this person says something good it's
just sad to me that this person was
attacked for all of it okay other things
that I hate so yesterday you will recall
that Andrew Cuomo said that America was
never that great
yeah and Andrew Cuomo who is indeed the
stupider Cuomo brother as he proved this
week a difficult title to seize from his
brother Crispin well Cynthia Nixon
responded it was really funny cuz
Cynthia Nixon is running against him for
governor of New York and Cynthia Nixon
responded by saying that he's a fake
he's a phony he talks like he thinks
socialists talk so now she gets to
outflank him by saying like he's not
anti-american enough
hey she's gradually dragging Andrew
Cuomo along with her just like the
socialist wing of the Democratic Party
is dragging the entire Democratic Party
along with them hand over hand by rope
it's pretty amazing and you can see it
even in our best friend Hillary Clinton
who is back she's back okay
so there's a there's a video that was
going around the internet of this little
11 year old girl who was kneeling for
the pledge of allegiance now if at 11
years old you're kneeling for the pledge
of allegiance it's fair to say that
you've probably been indoctrinated by
your parents in certain political
viewpoints here's what this little girl
did and there's a news story about it
and then we'll show you what Hillary had
to say about it I decided to kneel for
the school pledge and what I did so my
teacher she um she came up to me and she
told me that um what she basically
implied I was disrespecting the country
she brought up her family overseas which
to my current beliefs is that
she like legally this is not okay so I
feel bad for this girl I honestly I feel
bad for the girl because her parents put
her in the position of doing this in
front of her teacher and classmates it
is true that under Supreme Court law she
does not have to actually stand for the
Pledge of Allegiance or anything like
that right they think that's compelled
speech you can't do that in a classroom
however it is also true that it is bad
for eleven-year-old girls to be taught
that they should not stand for the
Pledge of Allegiance which is a unifying
feature of the United States and simply
recognizes that we live in the greatest
country ever found it so how far has the
Democratic Party moved here was Hillary
Clinton's response on Twitter she
tweeted this out it takes courage to
exercise your right to protest injustice
especially when you're 11 keep up the
good work Mariana okay I can't imagine
how in the world this woman lost the
presidency to Donald Trump how how could
that possibly have happened the fact
that the fact that the Democrats are so
deeply uncomfortable with basic
patriotism is one of the reasons why the
Democrats are losing the middle of the
country it's also one of the reasons why
the country is being torn apart it's
torn in half
because once the American flag becomes
something that is controversial what
exactly do we share anymore we don't
share religion we don't share central
values we don't share a belief in the
Constitution we don't believe I share a
belief in God given rights protected by
limited government we don't believe in
any of these things if the basic
symbolism of we at least like the
country goes away there's not much left
so it's it's it's really disturbing that
Hillary's doing this now I promised one
of our producers Colton Holden is
Quentin's job on the show is to find
weird stuff and Colton spends a lot of
time on the internet finding weird stuff
he says it's for the show I assume that
I assume that he's telling the truth and
he showed me this very very weird thing
that I felt I felt compelled to talk
about there are now people who dress
adults who dress as babies as a fetish
it's an actual thing and there's video
of these people and this exists on this
planet on planet earth and I hesitate to
inflict this on you but I'm just that
cruel so
here is a in a video about this
demonstrating you know what some of the
I would say more fringe elements
well what less understood elements put
less understood elements of our
population go through in pursuing their
jollies an adult baby is somebody who
enjoys dressing up and acting like a
baby well I've got my diaper changing
materials nice and close I've got my
puppy dog mobile when I have to make a
number two it's in the toilet
and no I don't sit in a wet diaper all
day long and of course I've got mine on
some of my favorite adult baby
activities would be playing with my my
DUPLO Legos you can build anything or
you can imagine
Colton you're fired
the reason to talk about this is because
when we say that we may be infantilizing
our adults when we may be saying that
may that if we look at that we go yeah
that seems strange
maybe we shouldn't all be like super
cool with that sort of thing then that's
considered intolerant it is intolerant
because how first of all I have a
question how do we know that that isn't
actually a baby he identifies as a baby
how do we know that that is not in fact
a small child in a giant man's body I
mean I feel like we are being absolutely
adult nor we're being age normative and
that is just wrong we should totally not
mock this in any way whatsoever when
when tolerance gets to the point where
men dressing in diapers and lying in
cribs is considered part of a media
coverage that ought to be you know given
that sort of credit I think maybe the
country has gone wrong maybe we've
brought up our kids a little bit wrong
so to go back to the main theme of the
show until people start recognizing that
there are some certain basic values that
we may want to inculcate in our kids
there ended up like that then we then
we're going to have some real problems
in the country okay well we will see you
back here next time i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the basic eurozone is produced by Sonia
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
Borah senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jess wah Alvaro the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire Ford publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018